bonjour à tous
alors cette position un peu particulière
c'est ce qu'on appelle une parure
posture une posture de pouvoir cette
position c'est ma grande sœur qui me l'a
montré au cours de mes études elle a été
très importante pour moi
déjà d'avoir ont montré que si on
connaît cette position avant un grand
examen ou avant un oral celle-ci nous
donnerait beaucoup plus confiance en
nous
en fait notre cerveau il associe cette
position à l'un des plus grands
super-héros de notre génération le grand
Superman vous savez ce super héros
combatif vaillant mais surtout qui finit
toujours par gagner on fait donc croire
en prenant cette position que nous aussi
on peut être aussi victorieux que le
grand Superman
alors j'ai été très impoli je me suis
même pas présenté je m'appelle Cyril
cawan j'ai 23 ans et je suis élève
ingénieur à l'école des Arts et Métiers
moi je suis pas ici sur le campus de
Paris je suis sur le campus de Bordeaux
alors moi j'ai fait mes études en banlie
parisienne je viens devant le parisienne
j'ai fait mon collège j'envoie le
Parisien j'ai fait mon lycée en banlieue
parisienne dans un petit appartement pas
très connu des services médiatiques le
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
comment j'ai trouvé mon cerveau et
comment je considère aujourd'hui avoir
réussi dans mes études en trompant donc
mon cerveau alors mon histoire commence
logiquement avec mes parents mes parents
sont immigrés algériens ils ont émigré
dans les années 90 d'Algérie de manière
légale
et ils n'ont pas fait de grandes études
mais nous ont transmis un grand savoir à
travers leurs diverses expériences on
perd par exemple il a arrêté l'école
très tôt pour devenir basketteur
professionnel c'est pour ça que c'était
très important pour lui que toutes ces
filles pratiquent du sport j'ai donc
commencé très tôt avec 10 ans de
natation en compétition alors j'avais
des programmes très chargés des horaires
très durs on agit des kilomètres et des
kilomètres tous les jours toutes les
semaines vacances comprises si on
n'écoutait pas on sortait de l'eau
c'était 50 pompes on va rentrer on
finissait notre série et nous
entraînements ils pouvaient aller
jusqu'à 23 heures minuit assez
facilement et pour le moment les
entraîneurs je les détestais
toute ma vie je vous ai détesté parfois
j'avais l'impression que mes entraîneurs
et mon père qui mon père attendait
jusqu'à minuit était en coalition pour
me faire souffrir
alors qu'en fait aujourd'hui quand j'ai
réfléchi quand j'y repense bah pas du
tout je comprends juste que ils ont
compris que ma motivation à moi est
passée par mon esprit de compétition
aujourd'hui je le vois tous les jours
dans mes études et au quotidien je sens
que commencer à vous il sait qu'il y a
un enjeu ou des personnes en face de moi
il arrive à exploiter un maximum de ses
capacités le sport a éduquer mon cerveau
et aujourd'hui je sais que j'aime la
compétition
je me suis toujours défié dans ma vie à
travers le sport donc au début et encore
aujourd'hui mais surtout à travers mes
études après le lycée j'étais un peu
comme beaucoup d'étudiants perdus je
savais pas trop ce que je voulais faire
j'ai décidé d'aller en classe
préparatoire sans réellement sans réel
encouragement de mes professeurs je suis
donc allée je suis allée dans le 93 donc
en classe préparatoire alors
pour la classe préparatoire pour ceux
qui ne savent pas ça se fait en deux ans
ces décors assez normaux donc 8 heures
18 heures avec des examens oraux écrits
tous les jours toutes les semaines
vacances comprises vous avez compris
et en entrant en entrant en prépa
j'étais assez perdu assez confuse d'un
côté c'était de l'excitation c'est un
nouvel environnement de travail de
nouveaux amis c'est la rentrée quoi mais
d'un autre côté j'étais assez perdue je
me sentais assez vulnérable j'avais de
moins en moins confiance en moi et
surtout je doutais beaucoup de moi-même
j'avais l'impression que j'étais
beaucoup moins forte que les autres
parce que je ne l'ai pas du même endroit
que
donc j'ai passé mes deux ans à
travailler d'arrache-pied à tout
sacrifier à sacrifier des moments des
personnes je voyais beaucoup moins
souvent mes amis ma famille et surtout
le sport
j'ai travaillé pendant deux ans à la fin
des années on passe des concours pour
entrer en école d'ingénieur donc les
concours passent je les passe les
résultats tombent et là bam je me foire
complètement je passe totalement à côté
pour moi c'était
un peu la fin de ma vie mon monde
s'effondre j'avais l'impression d'avoir
passé deux ans à travailler dur
d'arrache-pied à sacrifier plein de
choses pour au final avoir une école que
j'aurais pu avoir en sortant de lycée
pour moi c'était deux années perdues
deux années qui partent comme ça
alors je me souviens pas exactement de
cette période aujourd'hui je pense que
mon cerveau il a juste effacé cette
période parce que c'était beaucoup plus
simple mais c'est comme ça on avait
appuyé sur un bouton et là tout d'un
coup je me suis mon cerveau s'est mis en
mode machine ici dans une dynamique de
motivation et de détermination j'étais
déterminé à montrer que moi sur une
Kawan j'avais les capacités d'entrer
dans une grande école donc ma rentrée
arrive je m'en souviendrai je pense
toute ma vie je j'étais avec mon ami
Dragan au fond de la salle et mon prof
de physique fait sa présentation
habituelle vous savez bonjour à tous
Bienvenue etc et pendant sa présentation
il dit alors vous savez vous ici d'où
vous venez et où vous êtes aujourd'hui
vous n'obtiendrez jamais une grande
école
ensuite nous pointe du doigt dragon et
moi au fond de la salle pour nous dire
alors même eux n'atteindront pas une
grande école comme les arts et métiers
là je me suis retournée vers drakan pour
me dire mais j'aimerais tellement lui
donner tort donc ça montrait vraiment
que j'étais déterminée motivé et que
j'avais envie quoi et donc je travaille
les mois passent les jours passent et là
bam confinement je me retrouve chez moi
confiné chez ma famille seul trois mois
avant des concours qui concrètement
détermineront ma vie alors là c'est
encore un peu de confusion il est encore
partagé d'un côté j'arrive quand même à
créer une bulle de travail et à
travailler de manière efficace parce que
je me rendais celle simplement compte
que je travaillais mieux seul de chez
moi que avec mes amis à la prépa
mais d'un autre côté bah c'était un peu
je me sentais vraiment très seule
on avait plus de concours on n'avait
plus parlant de cours donc plus de profs
donc plus d'examens donc plus de notes
donc je pouvais plus du tout me situer
par rapport aux autres je connaissais
plus du tout mon potentiel je savais je
savais pas ce que je vais aller je
travaille un peu dans le vent donc ces
trois mois se passent les concours
arrivent je les passe et
là
incroyable enfin la surprise énorme je
suis admise aux arts et métiers alors je
sais pas si vous en rendez compte moi
c'était beaucoup de surpris c'est je
suis admise aux arts et métiers moi
Sirine Kawan je suis à Nice aux arts et
métiers
et pour moi c'était beaucoup
d'étonnement j'étais super surprise je
me sentais pas du tout capable je
pensais pas du tout avoir les moyens et
les capacités d'aller aussi loin et
d'atteindre l'une des plus prestigieuses
écoles de France et aujourd'hui je peux
dire que je suis moi aussi une super
héroïne je respire un bon coup d'abord
et je peux dire que moi aussi je suis
super héroïne parce que je suis fière
d'être la première étudiante
issue de la prépa alpeser du 93 à
rentrer aux arts et métiers depuis une
dizaine d'années je suis fière d'être la
première femme voilée à entrer aux arts
et métiers de Bordeaux
et surtout je suis fière d'être fille
d'immigré algérien qui ont tous sacrifié
pour leurs enfants et d'être dans l'une
des plus prestigieuses écoles de France
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]